So, here’s a statement that won’t blow
anyone’s mind: The SCP Foundation is really,
really, really weird.
And we’re not even talking about the actual
anomalies they contain.
Sure, this top-secret organization puts in
the time and the effort to make sure menaces
to society like the Hard to Destroy Reptile,
the Scarlet King, and even the horrifying
Bad Joke Tomatoes stay behind lock and key,
but sometimes, you need to hold a mirror up
to yourself and see just what the heck is
going on.
I mean seriously, think about it.
This is an organization that uses live human
beings farmed from death row as test subjects.
Considering how rarely the death penalty is
actually employed in the Western world these
days, you know some shady strings are being
pulled there.
And what about the O5 Council?
The leaders of humanity’s last line of defense
against anomalous chaos, and according to
some accounts, they’re a group of vain,
petty, and morally bankrupt individuals who
regularly use anomalies like SCP-006, the
Fountain of Youth, for their own personal
benefit.
And don’t even get me started on the actual
scientists working under the Foundation’s
payroll, that’s when things start getting
even stranger.
Of course, there’s Dr. Jack Bright, a man
forever changed by a chance interaction with
SCP-963, an anomalous medallion, and one of
Able’s deadly blades.
Now he’s an immortal weirdo who’s equal
parts brilliant and a total nuisance - so
much so that there’s an entire dedicated
list forbidding all of his zanier antics.
Then there’s Dr. Alto Clef.
Don’t even try to shake his hand, given
how much this ex-GOC wild card loves using
violence to solve his problems, you may draw
back a stump.
He specializes in reality warping anomalies,
often wields a ukulele cause he’s just so
darn quirky, oh, and he’s very likely the
baby-daddy to a teenage nature sprite after
a dalliance with a goddess.
Oh, and what about Dr. Charles Ogden Gears?
Sure, he may not look that strange to the
naked eye - he’s a man so dull and humorless
that gray is his favorite color and he thinks
sugar on cornflakes is an act of unacceptable
decadence - but he’s got a whole lot of
strangeness under the hood.
Like the fact he’s such an emotionally unavailable
father that his daughters across dimensions
have formed a splinter cell of the Serpent’s
Hand, where they work under the collective
pseudonym The Black Queen, just to spite him.
Dr. Dan, through acts of sabotage, was personally
responsible for the worst SCP-096 outbreak
in Foundation history, leading to the end
of thousands of lives - just so he could receive
clearance to terminate the creature.
And he got that clearance, on the condition
that the SCP Foundation would be terminating
him for his crimes as soon as the goal is
achieved.
And then there’s...
Oh my gosh...
Did someone dress a dog up in scientist clothes?
This is the cutest thing I’ve ever seen!
Oh, this has just brightened my day.
Maybe I was being too harsh on the Foundation
before.
Whose dog is this?
“Excuse me, sir!
That is extremely inappropriate!”
Wait, you can talk!?
“Of course I can talk, you dolt!
I’m Professor Kain Pathos Crow, one of the
SCP Foundation’s finest minds in the fields
of advanced robotics and biochemistry!
I have a Level 4 Clearance, for 343’s sake!
I’m not some common bloody mutt!”
Oh...
My apologies, Professor Crow.
I wasn’t aware you were a...
Well, a talking dog.
“Well, yes, I imagine there’s a lot you
don’t know about me, isn’t there?”
I’m a little embarrassed to admit it, but
that’s true, Professor Crow.
Our data on you and your work with the SCP
Foundation is a little sparse.
“Here, take these files.
These should give you a good primer.”
I suppose we better take this from the top,
then...
Professor Kain Pathos Crow, among a lineup
of extremely eccentric researchers, somehow
manages to rise to the very top in terms of
sheer strangeness.
To get the most obvious fact out of the way,
yes, while he was once a human, an anomalous
experiment did result in him being turned
into a Labrador Retriever.
How did this happen, you may ask?
We have the same question.
Sadly, Professor Crow is incredibly reluctant
to share any details about this strange and
embarrassing incident, so we’re just going
to have to accept it for what it is and move
on.
Everyone ready?
Okay, good.
Despite his strange appearance, Professor
Crow is actually one of the more scientifically
qualified of the Foundation researchers - it’s
no surprise that, because of this, he has
a relatively close working relationship with
Dr. Gears.
So much so that he still refers to Gears by
his early Foundation codename, COG, a reference
to both the legendarily stern doctor’s initials
and a pun on his iconic surname.
During one incident, Dr. Gears did tell Professor
Crow to terminate an anomaly - that was, for
all intents and purposes, a human child - if
it presented any difficulties.
This sours the wholesomeness of that previous
fact, so we’ll swiftly move on.
Once again, Dr. Gears is just terrible
with kids.
The other thing that’s kept him from being
turned into an extremely overqualified chew
toy for SCP-682 is the contents of his brilliant
brain.
On many of the occasions when the O5 Council
have considered terminating him, he’s demonstrated
the fact he possesses vital and often irreplaceable
knowledge, saving his furry skin.
A perfect example of the kinds of strange
scrapes that Professor Crow gets himself into
is the incident in 2009 where, without even
realizing it, he somehow traveled through
time and scared the living daylights out of
everyone.
The details are best expressed here, in Professor
Crow’s own dictated notes:
18/02/2009
In all my years working here, there have been
few things which have irritated me.
Cause me physical harm yes, cause me undue
stress yes, cause me innumerable amount of
mental distress yes, but few things have just…
irritated me.
Time travel is one of them.
I went to bed on the fifteenth of January
year two thousand and nine at one thirty a.m.
I woke up on February eighteenth at nine twenty
six a.m. of the same year.
I hadn't moved, I had only nine hours of sleep,
and to me nothing had happened.
Then after a slightly confused day amidst
the many cries of "I thought you were dead!?"
(among other things I might add), I discover
that I had been missing for the past month
and three days.
In that time, Sophia had completely taken
over my duties (though she had halted all
of my personal experiments), and was trying
her utmost to relocate me, while keeping my
disappearance form the higher ups.
Apparently, [DATA REDACTED] leaving me to
sleep in a small self contained bubble of
[DATA EXPUNGED] and making at least [DATA
EXPUNGED] which was eventually ruptured by
[DATA EXPUNGED] and sending back to this phase
of space and time.
Needless to say I was… slightly irritated
to say the least.
24/02/2009
Bah.
They've had me in quarantine for nearly the
past week, observing me and running tests
to see if they can find any sort of strange
abnormalities with my physiology, my behavior,
my anything.
If I have one more hand shoved up my neither
regions, or am forced to look at one more
bloody ink blot, I'm going to flip out and
go rabid.
They say they'll stop the quarantine soon,
and Sophia says the higher ups still haven't
caught onto anything.
I suppose I'm lucky in that count.
Normally the only time they quarantine something
is when it's too dead to be of any sort of
immediate security hazard.
Still, I guess I can see where they're coming
from.
If it were my decision, I'd probably force
a quarantine too, and probably for longer.
At least they had the decency to give me my
clothes, my PDA and someone to dictate to.
12/03/2009
I'm still here.
I'm still here and I hate it.
Day in, day out, it's the same thing.
Get up, eat, exercise, then simple observation
until lunch, then more observation until dinner,
then lights out.
I'm not allowed anything other than the things
I already have, and even then, I only got
those because Sophia felt bad for me.
I'm only allowed to use them every day for
an hour at most, otherwise they're also in
observational storage.
All this wasted time.
All this wasted time that I could have been
doing something constructive, something useful,
something interesting, but no, I'm stuck here
because of a wry twist of fate, forcing me
into this monotonous hell.
They keep telling me I'll be let out soon.
Liars.
05/05/2009
They've seen fit to release me.
I almost thought I was going to die in there.
Still, it almost seems strange to be out and
about again.
But I do appreciate being back in my own quarters,
my own clothes and my beloved walker back
by my side.
Sophia has taken good care of the facility
while I was gone.
I think I might actually leave that to her,
while I keep to my experiments.
She seems to enjoy it a great deal.
Suits her analytical mind.
All of my personal experiments are still waiting
for me, with the exception of the 040 test
logs.
They simply haven't posted their findings
yet, stating that they needed my approval
first, so I'll have to pore through those
at the first chance I get.
I'm interested in the progress she may have
made.
Still, there is a good deal of work to be
done and I am more than ready enough to take
it on.
After all, I have to make up for lost time,
don't I?
It’s clear that life isn’t easy for poor
Professor Crow.
Much like Dr. Bright, after experiencing the
mysterious event that turned him into a dog,
Professor Crow is both a researcher and an
anomaly.
And unlike the superficially subtle presentation
of Dr. Bright’s anomalous nature, it’s
hard to hide the strangeness of a talking
dog in human clothes.
This bizarre interstitial zone he occupies
forces the Foundation to keep him on an extremely
short leash - No pun intended.
Seriously, Professor, it wasn’t intended,
I swear!
Anyway, the point is, Professor Crow isn’t
allowed to clock off at the end of the workday
like his fellow researchers do.
He’s forced to remain on site, almost never
appearing in public.
If the Professor wasn’t the kind of person
who could easily get lost in his work, a situation
like this would probably drive him insane.
Speaking of which, you’re probably wondering
by this point: Other than being the cutest
researcher at the Foundation...
Sorry, Dr. Clef.
You’re special in your own way, we promise.
What kind of work is Professor Kain Pathos
Crow actually known for around here?
Professor Crow’s most notable body of work
is largely based on an opinion that’s pretty
controversial to hold around the SCP Foundation:
He believes that they should be actively utilizing
anomalies that aren’t dangerous in order
to further their collective goals.
An excellent example of this is the cordial
relationship he has with SCP-040, also known
as Evolution’s Child.
She’s a powerful reality warper who is able
to synthesize new anomalous life from pre-existing
living creatures.
Professor Crow, who refers to her as Emma
in his personal writings, was initially training
her to do this with SCP-148, the infamous
Telekill Alloy.
However, he also filed a formal request to
go further, saying, “I think it's about
time we started trying to utilize 040's abilities,
or at the very least, allowing her to use
them enough to actually learn how to control
them.
She will not be able to rely on the SCP-148
hairpieces forever.
We theorized that as she gets older, her powers
will increase exponentially, possibly to the
point where her unconscious telepathy cannot
be contained.”
He also, somewhat infamously, went ham with
a series of experiments using SCP-158, a frightening
anomalous device known as the Soul Extractor
- which, contrary to its name, Professor Crow
also realized could place removed souls into
other objects or creatures.
This led to the creation of a being that Crow
dubbed “Zero”, because it was Subject
Zero in his experiments to create a “composite
soul” using SCP-158.
He spoke of this subject, somewhat creepily,
in his notes:
“Zero would make an excellent candidate
for my assistant.
It respects and admires me for its creation,
much as a child would an endearing father
figure.
I have assured it that it would be treated
well, and that I will give it a host to the
best of my ability to create.
All that it asks of me is that it is given
a name other than Zero.
A name.
Not a number.
I told it to give itself a name, to christen
itself whatever it so wishes.
It told me it would have to think about it.”
Like a lot of strange and fascinating figures,
everything you learn about Professor Kain
Pathos Crow seems to raise new questions.
Is Crow just a mad scientist without a cause,
eager to perform bizarre experiments for their
own sake?
Well...
Not quite.
The sum total of all of Professor Crow’s
work is Project Olympia, a topic that probably
deserves a whole video in its own right - and
do sound off in the comments if you’d like
to hear more about the deranged Frankenstein
project that Professor Crow has devoted his
life to.
You see, Project Olympia is Crow’s baby,
and also his attempt to play God: Through
combining a variety of different anomalies
- including all the ones we’ve mentioned
here, and several others - he would hope to
create an entirely artificial living thing
that would serve the interests of the SCP
Foundation.
How exactly this would be beneficial to the
SCP Foundation is, admittedly, a little confusing,
but seeing this goal through to its conclusion
has become an all-consuming obsession for
Professor Crow.
He’s performed countless experiments with
a huge catalog of anomalies under the Project
Olympia umbrella.
He’s written reams upon reams of notes and
logs on the subject, and produced a huge number
of prototypes.
He also used Project Olympia as a pretense
to remove even more souls using SCP-158, because
that just appears to be a strange obsession
of his, doesn’t it?
Incidentally, we aren’t the only ones confused
about the exact purpose and value of Project
Olympia.
When members of the O5 Council finally got
a proper look at Professor Crow’s work with
the Project, they released the following statement.
“All activity related to Project Olympia
has been discontinued.
Overwatch Command has deemed it to be a gross
waste of resources, and permanently removed
support for the project, with personnel assigned
to work with it being moved to alternate sites.
A hearing is to be held with the project administrators
to determine how the project was able to continue
as long as it did despite the lack of any
concrete results.
Prototypes and other equipment have been slated
to be decommissioned.”
Professor Crow took this news about as well
as you could expect, but in the end, he always
finds a way to wriggle out and continue doing
whatever he wants to do.
Because that’s what Professor Kain Pathos
Crow is all about.
He’s living proof that sometimes, you just
can’t keep a good dog down.
Now go check out “SCP Immortal Dr. Bright
Explained” and “Dr. Clef - SCP Foundation
Researcher” for more explainers of the SCP
Foundation’s most eccentric researchers!